reading the script for the first time
you sort of have this bittersweet
reaction where it's like oh but oh
because it's over and uh
yeah it's i mean we i don't know what we
can and we can't say
but i think bittersweet if i could wrap
it up in one word that would be it
joe and hero i mean seeing the fan
reaction to
after was there added pressure for you
guys going
into filming after we collided the
entire world is a collection of
memoranda that she did exist
and that i have lost her this is our
story
tessa's and mine no i think you kind of
just try to take it as support rather
than pressure
um obviously there is a little bit but i
guess you just kind of
gotta interpret it as just nothing but
but a good sign and i think it is
nothing but that so um
yeah that's how i interpret it anyway
yeah i
would say the same thing i think you
have to take it as support um
rather than pressure and there's always
expectation there and i think you just
try your best to
um not let it uh affect the work too
much
this sequel continues with so much
passion
and emotion and romance for your
characters in particular
what is your your relationship like off
camera and how do you guys
get to a place of trust and comfort with
each other
that helps your professional
relationship i'd say i mean we're
we're good friends we get along with we
i think the set is just super
it's super professional and i think cast
crew production and everyone from the
start has made it like that and then
obviously as you go
the fact you've worked together before
you don't see each other for a whole
year and you come back
and it you could pretty much just pick
up where you left off so we're super
lucky to be able to do more than
more than one film and every time it
kind of just gets
i wouldn't say easier but uh there's
there's less eyes to break
each time yeah i think it's a lot to do
with the environment you're in
and and when you're working with um
professionals and
everyone's everyone knows what they're
doing it's just really easy to get back
into it
dylan what was it like for you coming
into this franchise to play
trevor matthews especially knowing how
rabid the fan base is
in support of of of hessa's storyline
you know what was it like for you coming
into this
i mean i want to give you like a crazy
cool
answer to this but it was pretty
straightforward um
i uh everyone was really inviting and
welcoming
and the fan base is rabid because
they're really passionate about it which
is cool to see
it's nice to step into a series or a
project where people are really
impassioned
to like it so much and and so for me it
was it was nice it was easy
and uh like they could have already
mentioned all the ice had been broken
so i kind of just walked on the set and
everyone was enjoying themselves and
knew each other and makes a really great
film
and now you have your own hashtag i
can't even say the first word of it
because it's an expletive but everyone
says effing trevor
yeah yeah so if the opportunity came
about for you to be a part of the third
installment
would you want to continue trevor's
storyline
well it really depends on the contract
that they write up i think
um you know this is a business after all
um so at the end of the day that's
that's a little outside of me and
has more to do with uh with the powers
that be i am just
a humble actor i read the lines and i
speak the words
you know what i love the honesty and the
transparency and that literally
just made my day joe and hero back to
you guys really quick um anna told me
that you have already started production
for the next installments and i know
that
you guys all can't say much a lot is
under lock and key but
uh what was your reaction to reading the
script for the first time
uh i think if there's a little reading
the script for the first time
you sort of have this bittersweet
reaction where it's like
oh but oh because it's over and uh
yeah it's i mean we i don't know what we
can and we can't say
but i think bittersweet if if i could
wrap it up in one word that would be it
okay i like bittersweet here what about
you
yeah i was just gonna i feel like um
it just feels like if it feels like
we're in a pretty nice
kind of pace and it's a bit of that
routine now to be honest i don't think
anything it feels like just kind of like
almost with this consistency that you
rarely get if you're not doing like a
franchise with multiple movies
we're really lucky to kind of have this
this same base and same production same
people
it really we just pick up where we left
off each time and it's like a
it's a real luxury to be honest to
have have the same team to be working
with each time